thank you
thank you so much thank you so much when
I was a teenager and started liking
girls I could never find the right words
to express myself and after a couple of
words they just walk away leaving me
figuring out what do I need to do to get
a date and so being a music fan of 1970s
rhythm and blues love songs I put
together a strategy to recite the lyrics
to get a date so for girls i liked i
would pull out some Al Green or some
teddy pendergrass awesome I actually
brothers and I recite the lyrics to
their love songs but for people I loved
if I fell in love with a girl oh I had
to dig down deep get some Stevie Wonder
to fully express the love I have for
them for the girl so today I'm gonna
pull out some Stevie Wonder for these
families
so families close your eyes and just
imagine me back in 1974 with an afro and
some bell-bottoms and y column we all
know sometimes life's hate and troubles
can make you wish you were born in
another time and place but you can bet
your life times that and twice it's
double that God knew exactly where he
wanted you to be placed so make sure
when you say you're not in it but not of
it you're not helping to make this earth
a place sometimes call he'll change your
words into truth and then change that
truth into love and maybe your
children's grandchildren and their great
great grand jury will tell them I'll be
loving you until the rainbow burns the
stars out of the sky i'll be loving
until the ocean covers every mountain
high i'll be loving you until the
dolphin flies and the parrots live at
the seat i'll be loving you until we
dream of life and life becomes a dream
i'll be loving you until the day is
night and night becomes the day i'll be
loving to you onto the trees and seize
up up and fly away i'll be loving you
until the day that 8 times 8 times 8
times 8 is 4 i'll be loving you until
the day that is the day that are no more
i'll be loving you until the day the
earth starts turning right to the left
i'll be loving you until the earth just
for the sun denies itself i'll be loving
you until mother nature says her
is true I'll be loving you until the day
that you are me and I am you now ain't
that loving you
unto the rainbow burns the stars out of
the sky ain't that loving you until the
ocean covers every mountain and I've got
to say always I'll be loving you always
and there's no greater love than this
that these five men gave their lives for
all of us